for more in the story now let's bring in
our correspondent Philip Whalen who's in
Rome for us Philip the state funeral
service will begin in about a half an
hour what can we expect clearly it's
going to be a very emotional occasion as
you mentioned a lot of anger about this
tragedy which many people feel was
avoidable it should never have happened
and people are still looking for who was
responsible in this case we have a new
anti-establishment government in power
many of its top officials will be
present and it's going to be hard to
blame them for what happened the ground
saw what happened late a long time in
the past but clearly a lot of anger a
lot of grief and there could be some
angry reactions to officials appearing
for the funeral now a lot of anger and a
lot of grief as you say yourself some of
the victims relatives have declared that
they they will stay away from today's
funeral service why are they so angry
with the government that they would say
something like that yes a number of
people actually more than half of the
victims are not going to be present at
the funeral today in some cases people
say that simply they want to have the
funeral in their hometown where friends
and relatives can attend more easily but
they've also been very angry reactions
people suggesting that their loved ones
were the victims of a state homicide so
it makes no sense to participate in a
state funeral that I think is a strong
feeling because this is the national
infrastructure that the state is
ultimately responsible for and so people
do feel that the state and those who
represent it are a fault here and they
don't want to participate in a ceremony
with their representatives of that state
so very clear-cut responses there no the
FIR responsible for the maintenance of
the bridge is due to hold a news
conference shortly there's a lot of
pressure on them not just to provide
answers but also to possibly compensate
families to build the bridge and to pay
for the bridge what kind of actions are
they planning to take do you reckon and
well we'll have to wait and see but
certainly the company has suggested that
it does want to provide financial
support for victims families and also
for the many people who've been made
homeless by its tragedy they've also
said that they're willing to help
rebuild the infrastructure of Genoa a
lot though will depend if the government
moves ahead with revoking their license
a lot will depend really on negotiations
with the government clearly major
financial commitments to restore the
transport network in Genoa makes sense
if you believe that you're going to get
your license back if you're not going to
get the license back that could reduce
the generosity of the company but
clearly there's enormous pressure on
them many people feel that they're
deeply at fault and they need to try and
recover some of the Lost goodwill wait
and see what they have to say if there's
news conference Phillip Willem in
Finland willing in Rome thank you